ce jour 13 de la campagne électorale ou
l'art de la bonne prononciation
quand la campagne prend un peu l'air
jean françois lisée se met dans la peau
des gens déjà dit c'est le pq surprend
énormément ah oui c'est lisez là n'est
pas vrai qu'on passait avant la campagne
elle va bien elle est proche des gens
proches de ce pêcheur de 76 ans par
exemple qui lui parle des quotas c'est
pourquoi vous vous rendez vous 20
familles vachement content de la pêche
mais si ça marche pas mais aussi ma
prononciation un peu fantaisiste aussi
du côté de la cac
je sais pas car je dis ça monsieur sympa
de pierre paul doit bien sonné manon
massé a eu de la chance on ce jour 13
elle parle réduction des gaz à effet de
serre et au même moment en arrière-plan
il faut se mettre absolument au travail
elle parle congestion et transports en
commun au niveau du transport collectif
on le sait qu'un enjeu de congestion par
exemple le matin ici mathieu prostré du
canada
[Musique]